PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
Today we're going to do another
example of a definite integral.
This time, it's going
to be one that you're
going to need to do
some substitution for.
You're not going to know
the antiderivative right
off the top of
your head, I think.
So, I've got it on
the board behind me.
So it's compute the
integral from minus 2 to 2
of the function x squared
cosine of the quantity
x cubed over 8 dx.
So, this is a kind
of a weird integrand.
Roughly, you know,
very, very rough graph
of kind of what it looks like.
So this is sort of the
area of this region.
It's a positive function
over this interval.
So it's the area of this region
that I'm asking you to compute.
So, all right, so
definite integral.
Why don't you pause the
video, take a couple minutes,
work this out
yourself, come back, we
can work it out together.
All right, welcome back.
So, from looking at
this integrand here,
it seems to me that I
don't know immediately
off the top of my head
what its antiderivative is.
So, I can't just sort of
apply the fundamental theorem
of calculus directly without
a little bit of work.
So there are two
different ways that I
can go about computing
this then, about computing
this definite integral.
One is, that I can
forget for the minute
that it's a definite integral
and compute the antiderivative
and then use the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
So, let's try that way first and
then we'll do it a second way
as well.
So, method one is to
compute the antiderivative.
So we compute the
antiderivative of x squared
cosine of x cubed over 8 dx.
So here, it's not a
definite integral anymore.
Now I'm just looking
at the antiderivative.
And so, OK, so
either by intelligent
guessing or that--
I forget if that's
what Professor
Jerison called it--
or by just a
substitution method.
So, a good thing
to substitute here,
is we see inside this function
we have this x cubed part
and then outside we
have an x squared part.
So x squared dx,
that's closely related
to the differential of x cubed.
So we might try
the substitution--
we might try the substitution
u equals-- well we can maybe
get rid of all of
that at once-- so make
u equals x cubed over 8.
So in that case, du is
equal to 3/8 x squared dx.
And so this integral is equal
to the integral of-- well so,
x squared dx, we have that.
So we need to multiply
and divide by 3/8.
So this is, 8/3 cosine of u du.
All right, and so
now, OK, so the 8/3,
that's just a constant.
That pulls out in front.
That's not hard.
So then the
antiderivative of cosine
u du, that's something we know.
So this is 8/3 of minus
sine-- sorry not minus;
I was doing the derivative
instead of the antiderivative.
Just 8/3 sine u.
OK.
And good.
So that's the anti--
plus the constant, which
we don't need
because we're going
to plug this in the
fundamental theorem of calculus
in a minute.
So it's 8/3 sine u.
And, OK, so, but
that's not good.
I need it back in
terms of my x's.
And so I have to
back-substitute.
So this is 8/3 sine
of x cubed over 8.
All right, now I've
got an antiderivative
of this expression.
So now I can take
this antiderivative
and apply fundamental
theorem of calculus, Right?
So, the integral
from minus 2 to 2
of x squared cosine of x cubed
over 8 dx is equal to-- well
it's equal to this
antiderivative-- 8/3 sine x
cubed over 8 taken between x
equals minus 2 and x equals 2.
So this is equal to 8/3 times
sine of 1 minus 8/3 times
sine of minus 1.
OK, and sine of minus x
is equal to minus sine x.
So we could rewrite this
as 16/3 times sine of 1.
So that's the answer.
That's the value
of this integral.
And we did this first
method by first computing
the antiderivative
and then using it
with the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
The second way we
can do it is the one
that we just learned
more recently in lecture.
Which is to use
substitution directly
in the definite integral.
So let me come over
here and do that.
So, method two.
So now, when we do it this way,
mostly this looks the same.
So we start off, we don't
go back to antiderivative.
We start off with the
definite integral.
So that's one difference.
We can use the exact
same substitution.
So we can use exactly
the substitution
that we used before, which
was u equals x cubed over 8.
That doesn't change.
And we still have the same du
is equal to 3 x squared over 8,
but what does
change-- sorry, dx.
Good.
You need a differential always
to be equal to a differential.
So what does change
is that this-- I need
to change the bounds.
Right?
If I'm keeping it as definite
integrals all the time,
so I'm changing here from
an integral with respect
to x to an integral
with respect to u.
And so that means
that when I write down
the second integral
with respect to u,
the bounds that I write down
have to be the bounds for u.
Not for x.
So when x is equal
to minus 2, I need
to know what the
corresponding value of u is.
So in this case, when
x is equal to minus 2,
we see that the
lower bound here--
when x is equal to minus
2-- the lower bound on u
becomes u equals, well,
minus 2 cubed over 8.
That's minus 1.
And when x is equal
to 2, the upper bound,
u becomes 2 cubed over 8.
So u becomes 1.
So we have this extra step
when we do it this way,
of changing the bounds.
OK, so I do that.
So now I get the integral.
So I'm going to write
u equals minus 1
here just to remind myself
that I made this change to 1.
OK, and now the inside
transforms exactly the same.
So it's 8/3 times cosine u du.
OK, and now again, this is
something for which I already
know the antiderivative.
So I apply the fundamental
theorem of calculus here.
So I get the integral is
equal to 8/3 sine of u,
where u goes between
minus 1 and 1.
So the other thing that's
changed here is that now I
don't have to change this
back in terms of x's.
I have the values that I'm
going to plug in here already
in terms of u.
So I don't have to switch
back in terms of x's.
And so I just plug these values
in and take the difference.
So this is equal to 8/3 sine
of 1 minus 8/3 sine of minus 1,
which as we said before
is 16/3 times sine of 1.
OK, so we have these
two different methods.
They're very, very, very,
similar in how you apply them.
The key differences
are, that when
you do it, the substitution in
terms of definite integrals,
you have to change your
bounds of integration.
And what you get for changing
your bounds of integration is
at the end you don't have to
switch back from u's into x's.
Whereas, if you do it by first
computing the antiderivative,
well, you don't have any
bounds of integration
when you compute the
antiderivative so you
don't have to change them.
But once you computed
the antiderivative,
then you have to go and
make your back substitution.
Put everything back in
terms of x's before going on
to compute the definite
integral that you started with.
So the those are the
two different ways
you can do substitution
in definite integrals
and I'll end with that.